hello welcome to this video empty seats
a row one game one loss can talk about
her too yeah go on for revenge down he
takes you five is better move but I'm
happy to play the the the Roxy point
night h6 is a pretty uncommon line
oh absolutely cannot remember how it is
played fatigue on f5 is there no Bishop
t4 I can actually take age 6 I think
this is how the line goes you should be
for Bishop h6 something like that I
think it's it's no good for black bit
tricky so much tricky business
the issue with this pawn structure is
that long-term the dnd porn anyporn a
week n term what black has are some some
peas activity but is it enough it's the
it's the issue in most cases some it's
not enough so let's see what he's doing
here going back let's let's get rid of
that Bishop there from default
not quite clear if I need to do that ok
is going to see five
so let's see how to do this a couple of
interesting moves I even just a three
looks tempting to threaten before you
see is completely unimpressed by
long-term weaknesses but maybe yet to do
it
can you take a to do blunder stuff no
okay we maybe I didn't right along I
didn't see it also Janet this is wasn't
am as great as i was thinking maybe you
can still play this this position we
should be six or so
hmm
hmm what you got can go in the dark
square the possible I don't don't quite
see how do you wanna threaten meet what
also it would have been interesting
maybe I should have just done that
surprisingly you just goes back
could have gone to c3 also that would
have been a bit easier queen bee to now
might be a move f1 ig4 was still
possible I think I'm threatening
everyone now of course it is duly
ignored maybe I'm not threatening a
forward i think i'm i am
black resigns that's a very weird game
the whole line is strange but yeah and
this is this is this is known looks
normal yeah that also looked kind of
normal to me and now I went night be
five which is debatable but I wanted to
somehow get rid of that bishop I was
thinking it just goes back to have six
or so but you put it here I'm 83 and 85
yeah the engine gives 95 and gives black
a good game maybe maybe not G forces the
issue him and of course that's just just
just the threat of taking on d3 and f2
hmm 983 was a bad move computer wants to
work AE one but its beliefs that
blackest can ok interesting I probably
not be five wasn't the greatest idea
ever but I didn't really take Bishop c5
into account ok so this and again that
wasn't so bad now here he could have
taken on on f 2 plate 9 a-4 too quick to
quickly check could have taken him rukan
shakes quick eggs Queen takes rook
chicks game and i won check and I'm a
porn down no instead this was played ya
know why this a lot better you should
see two was interesting ok now I think I
know that that wasn't right i think ok
i'm sure before yeah i saw that but i
thought there was some kind of tactic
now of course if success is still
hanging so of course this is this is
this doesn't make any sense i still
can't take it six okay so a ch3 group
the eight and then four wins yeah a
shaky game but i'm glad that i did have
found that I've wanted not having a good
good streak at the mode thanks for
watching